00- The fire I see in the eyes
of the 19, 20, 25-year-old
that feels that
they're entitled to this
and then the flip side
the diminishing just
a little bit of ashes
with a little smoke left
of that same entrepreneur
when they were 22 at 46
when practicality and
family dynamics and the history
and the market tearing down
and the lack of that same
opportunity has just
dwindled down to a moment
where they don't believe that
they've got that shot and
I'm here to tell you
you absolutely do.
There are absolutely a ton
of entrepreneurs that started
their companies in
their 40s, 50s, 60s and 70s
when it was difficult
to do such a thing.
Sidney Frank
who created Grey Goose
didn't invent his big thing
until he was in his 70s.
And so, I'm desperate.
I'm desperate to give
you the springboard to say
"You know what?
Instead of watching
"'House of Cards' seasons,
"instead of trying to
go to ball games
"or things of that nature,
"yeah, I do have 7 P.M.
'til 2 in the morning
"Monday through Friday."
Heck, for a lot of you the
kids are out of the house.
Let's get into the
practicality for the
late 40s, 50s, 60-year-olds
that are watching this right now.
The kids are out of the house.
Yeah, you could pick up golf
or you could finally
start that candle company
because you put pretty pictures
of candles on Instagram
and it happens.
Learn the craft.
Figure out the
opportunity at hand.
Go attack it.
You only live once.
When you're 90 to
100-years-old and
you're regretting that you
never built this business
and you let this era pass,
this moment where there's
so much entrepreneurial upside,
you'll regret it and
regret is the worst.
I mean that's what it is.
(light music)